make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are getting back into the
marauders and the Marauders is probably
the best comic coming out of Marvel
right now like it's it's amazing um
here's the thing right this is actually
a really really interesting story this
one initially picks up with Sebastian
Shaw right Sebastian Shaw of course
being the black king of the Hellfire
Club the guy who can absorb pretty much
a limitless amount of energy and turn it
into a physical strength and what Ian's
up doing here is the extras of traveling
to the five now of course those guys who
have been keeping up with Don and ex the
five are the five mutants who are
responsible for resurrecting other
mutants who have basically died right
each one plays a particular role in
resurrecting various mutants who are out
there now they don't just do it
willy-nilly there's usually a cause or
there has to be a justification for a
mutant being resurrected they had to
serve a particular purpose and this is
really more of like an editorial concept
by Marvel to basically ensure that like
writers aren't just arbitrarily bringing
mutants back nobody wants to see Cronus
the untouchable come back oh not me of
you guys know who he was he was a guy
who could create force fields and then
suffocated in the side of his own force
field he sucked well he was a really
crappy mutant so because of that he was
a terrible character because of that
what we end up finding out here is that
the five at the request of Sebastian
Shaw have resurrected shinobi Shaw now I
don't know if you guys know who he is
shinobi Shaw is basically like the
illegitimate son of Sebastian and he has
the ability to increase or decrease his
density right so he can be like he deep
ride and they give self intangible or he
can make himself super durable like
super dense and almost indestructible
right so he's like vision in that regard
the funny thing about this is that
though the way this plays out or at
least the way this goes down is the
questions asked by Sebastian Shaw will
shinobi remember anything right anything
basically leading up to the time in
which he died and the response of the
five is well he shouldn't but there's a
possibility that he might it really just
depends right so one of the things that
this shows here is that when a character
is resurrected or characters brought
back if their memories weren't stored
inside cerebro there's no way to
guarantee what they will and won't
remember presumably if their memories
were stored inside cerebro what they
could do is engineer their memory so
they come back but don't remember
certain things which is actually a
really cool concept that could be used
if it's done properly in Marvel Comics
but the reason why this matters is
because the first thing Shinobi asks
Shaw is how did I get here and show how
it kind of has this recollection back to
wind shinobi died now here's an
important thing about his character
shinobi was really a result of Marvel in
the early 1990s trying to like
reshuffle the landscape right so we've
talked about this before in Xmen
explained when we explained the
publication history of the of the team
and the idea was at a 1991 Chris
Claremont from 91 and 92 you basically
bailed and so in early you're really
kind of late 1991 John Byrne took over
and the reason why that mattered because
John Byrne had done a lot of the art
alongside Chris Claremont is writer in
the x-men titles which is really where
John Byrne made his claim to fame that
in the art work he did on Fantastic Four
back in the day now he also wrote
stories where he did things like
she-hulk so it was like the first
instance where she basically broke the
fourth wall was under John Byrne but one
of the big things that that Marvel had
done is it basically looked at a lot of
the work that Chris Claremont had done
and because he had basically just left
Marvel just was gone he was there one
day and gone the next and went over to
DC to write that terrible sovereign 7
story when he had left Marvel basically
wanted to kind of undo all the stuff
that he did or kind of tie up loose pot
threads right and so Sebastian Shaw was
kind of considered to be an archaic
holdover Claremont had done a lot of
work with him but the role this shop
played was of the black king of the
Hellfire Club and that was a world that
could be occupied by anybody and so the
idea was to basically remove Sebastian
Shaw and replace him with a new
character and so what you ended up
getting was the introduction of Shinobi
and really he kind of got his claim to
fame as part of a group called the
upstarts now the upstarts was a concept
that was introduced because Shinobi I
think first appeared back in the old
x-factor comics and the upstarts were a
group that were introduced back in 1991
when Selene had become the black queen
of the Hellfire Club of course Selene
being a character who she was basically
10,000 years old
she'd been around for a long long time
and buying sneaking her way in there
what she wanted to do was basically
create her own inner circle and so she
had gotten with a guy called the game's
master and basically had him track down
and gather together a whole bunch of
different mutants and what they would do
is kill as many other mutants as he
possibly could and then there would be
awarded points the result was that in in
uncanny x-men issue number 282
you ended up having a Sebastian Shaw who
was killed early supposedly killed by
Shinobi no it didn't play out Sebastian
Shaw
actually ended up surviving these the
whole ordeal and Shinobi because of the
fact that mothers Jaime got into the mid
1990s Marvel was struggling a lot of the
plot threads that were there from John
Byrne ended up being either picked up or
abandoned by Scott Liddell and a few
other writers and so by the time he got
into like the late 1990s Chenault he was
just a character who was there he did a
few things here in there but none of
them were nearly as significant as what
Sebastian Shaw had done and so the
result of that is that Shinobi just kind
of free flowed and kind of graduated and
sort of existed over time until you
to Craig Hale with Exeter crochet now
shinobi had been killed by that point
and the result was that during ex
Nicosia because what you had was Saleem
returning and basically having this
transmode virus which which could
essentially resurrect the dead what she
did is she brought back shinobi and then
should nobody return to the landscape
yet again of course he went after
Sebastian Shaw a few things went down
then he going to Matt Rosenberg's
uncanny x-men around vol 5 in 2018 and
early 2019 and then basically you get to
issue number 20 and shinobi ends up
running his hand to his through his head
and killing himself as that's basically
why should nobody ended up dying more or
less shinobi explained in like 3 or 4
minutes right I mean I don't know if his
character really warrants a full-on
explanation because he's not really that
significant what I've told you I think
is good enough to really understand his
character but that's why he's here but
the idea behind Sebastian Shaw is to see
whether or not shinobi really remembers
everything that's basically gone down
and the result is that shinobi does
right I mean should nobody try to
actually take over Sebastian Shaw's role
as the black King at one point in time
and I think he almost succeeded but he
basically been gunning after his father
for quite some time by trying to kill
Sebastian Shaw for quite some time and
resurrecting and coming back and saying
well I still want to kill my dad
indicates that of course he basically
remembers all those various things that
have gone on between the two of them but
the animosity between the two really
seems to have been quelled for the time
being and the reason why is because what
is up happening here is one Sebastian
Shaw basically has shinobi put on him on
a red suit now this matters if you've
been following Marauders because what we
found out is that originally Sebastian
Shaw was the one who is going to appoint
the Red Queen or the Red King now his
pick of course was going to be shinobi
but my a virtue of some telepathic
finagling and basically just good
old-fashioned hard work by him a frost
she ended up being the one to secure
that position and Kitty Pryde ended up
becoming the Red Queen of course Kitty
Pryde being the pirate queen by the
pilot queen of the x-men so it's it's
cool I think that's a really cool name
right like the pirate queen of cacoa
that's a badass name I love that name
but basically what isn't happening here
is Sebastian Shaw really begins to this
kind of show shinobi everything that's
going on now the reality of this is this
is really more of kind of a filler story
than anything but it's also sort of a
good way to be introduced to what's
going on if you're getting on to
Marauders late that was good to see that
this is actually what's happening here
it's good to see that what at least what
Jerry Dugan is doing here is kind of
continually offering new readers away to
kind of get into the story right because
really the first little quarter of this
the first third of this is
literally Sebastian Shaw running over
all the things that we already know that
the mutant nation of capella provides
various medicines to the human world and
the result is that there are some human
nations that will publicly support the
mutant population because they do they
basically operate through Emma Frost as
the white queen of the Hellfire Club and
she's the one that basically publicly
provides medicines and and supplies to
those various nations that publicly
support the x-men for the various
nations that publicly oppose the x-men
but secretly desire to get their hands
on their medicines that's where
Sebastian Shaw comes in he's the black
King therefore he operates inside the
black market and then you have the Red
Queen Kitty Pryde who basically travels
from place to place free mutants from
nations that won't allow those mutants
to escape and travel trooper color right
so she's kind of the one that just moves
around from place to place and that's
basically what it is a Sebastian Shaw is
telling his son that goes on here but
it's kind of funny because as you get
into this and as you see the two of them
talking what you see is a lot of
manipulation by Sebastian Shaw what he
basically does here is he really kind of
skews everything and tells the son well
I was the one who was supposed to
appoint the Red King but Emma Frost lied
and she cheated as she was dubious as
she used her powers and really kind of
like demonizing the character of Emma
Frost and making her look bad in the
face of Shinobi by saying like she's
manipulative and she's a terrible person
and she's the one that basically duped
Sebastian Shaw making himself look like
the good guy and kind of the innocent
person in this now this is important
because what it shows is the lengths by
which Sebastian Shaw will go to to
achieve his goal the Sebastian Shaw has
always and will always be a very
manipulative and villainous character
more or less and that's really kind of
what's going on here and that's the
important thing to bear in mind is
because while you do have a lot of these
various mutants who are serving as part
of pro Khoa at the end of the day they
all really still do have their own mecha
nations now they operate and try to
achieve those Meccans while not
deviating too far away from their color
so they can maintain their status right
because what we've seen is that if a
mutant in the case of Sabretooth if a
mutant goes that runs alive if they
become too extreme they run against
krikawa or possibly even sabotage or
jeopardize Krakauer's sovereignity as a
nation they'll be banished right they'll
be locked inside the island of cacoa and
nobody wants to be locked down there
right because it's just a terrible place
to be in you're literally just sitting
there in darkness by yourself presumably
we don't really know what else down
there but Sebastian Shaw in order to
maintain his position and to ensure the
continued use of his power is kind of
manipulative and sort of moving things
around like
chess pieces in his own favor and his
son is no different here and so
ultimately what he basically ends up
saying is you're going to serve is like
the Bishop of the Hellfire Club right
now if guys were unfamiliar the Hellfire
Club really are like chess pieces right
the white queen the black queen the
white keen the black King the white rook
the black rook and so on and so forth
through all your various chess pieces
until you get two pawns which are
usually deemed as like henchmen of the
Hellfire Club the idea of bringing his
son on is a bishop is designed to
basically say hey look I can't really
have a Red King or a Red Queen that
positions held for kitty pryde but
secretly coveting that position so that
if the time comes when Kitty Pryde
somehow befall some tears some terrible
fate and is somehow killed or incapable
of being able to serve her purpose well
then here's a waiting member ready to
take her place in the form of chew Dobby
Shaw how Oh what a coincidence you know
that's really the kind of thing that
this Sebastian Shaw is going for here
it's very manipulative but that's how
his character operates it falls right in
line with the charter of the Hellfire
Club so that's when you really find out
how devious he's being here when should
nobody really ask the question says how
was it that I died here and that's the
thing he doesn't know how he died that's
the ones thing Sebastian Shaw wanted to
ensure is that when Shinobi came back
Shinobi wouldn't know how it was that he
died and that's when Sebastian Shaw says
it was basically the White Queen and the
Red Queen that conspired against you
they conspired against you to kill you
and remove you from the landscape
essentially telling his son they're the
reason why you died you have to get
revenge on them it's pretty shady but
again this is why I love everything a
dawn of X every story is unique and
amazing and fantastic that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here two comments
explain and make sure you guys are the
sub button to become part of the Rob
fort if you guys want to check out my
vs. videos and my uncensored videos head
over to patreon compound and if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace I want to give a shout out to
Jason see Austin s Jason s Austin H
Phillip and Austin B we have a lot of
Austin's and our patreon as well as G
gnosis 916 de gnosis didn't give us the
first and last name so we kind of had to
roll with it I didn't mention your last
names after you guys didn't want me to
throw them out there but I want to say
thank you to you all by the way your
four rings should be on their way for
our honor guard members of the rob corps
for these special patrons your custom
rob pour rings should be on their way
they're being shipped to me after that I
will have them shipped to you stay tuned
keep your eye on patreon and your
messages and you will hear about them
coming to you thank you
[Music]